saludos en los vídeos anteriores
hablamos sobre las diversas funciones
del dinero y las personas usualmente
mencionan tres funciones principales del
dinero como medio de intercambio es lo
que usamos para intercambiar por bienes
el segundo es el depósito de valor si
conservamos nuestro dinero va a mantener
su valor y la tercera función es la
unidad de cuenta que quiere decir que
normalmente pensamos en el valor de las
cosas en términos de la moneda local y
en algunos textos le agregan una cuarta
función a el dinero y dicen que el
dinero es el estándar de pago diferido
qué significa esto el pago diferido se
refiere a cuando recibimos cualquier
cosa y pagamos por ella después y la
forma más común de pago diferido es la
deuda digamos que aquí estamos nosotros
y queremos que nos presten diez mil
pesos
quizá pedimos el préstamo a alguna
institución como un banco y digamos que
es un préstamo de diez mil pesos
mediante una tarjeta de crédito así que
recibimos este préstamo lo usamos y
quizás después de cierto tiempo no sé
quizás después de un mes antes de que
llegue nuestro estado de la tarjeta de
crédito pues hacemos el pago devolvemos
este dinero y pagamos nuestra deuda con
dinero y esta es una de las formas más
comunes en las que recibimos algo y
después de cierto tiempo lo devolvemos
solo pagamos pero hay otras formas de
pago diferido como por ejemplo cuando
van a un restaurante y primero comen y
después pagan esta es una forma de pago
diferido y pues recibimos primero
nuestra comida y después ya que
terminamos de comerla
la pagamos aunque esperemos que la
cuenta del restaurante no sea de diez
mil pesos y en la actualidad usamos el
dinero para hacer estos pagos esta sería
su cuarta función pero pueden darse
cuenta del por qué algunas personas no
están de acuerdo con esta cuarta función
dicen que esto cae en la categoría de un
medio de intercambio es lo mismo que
usar el dinero para comprar una silla
servicios legales o comida usamos el
dinero para pagar nuestra deuda y esta
es otra forma con la que intercambiamos
dinero así que porque esto debería estar
separado bueno un ejemplo del por qué
esto puede estar separado porque el
estándar de pago diferido cumple una
función particular y esto es porque en
la economía actual existe algo que
respalda a esta idea de que el dinero
sirva como estándar de pago diferido es
decir si adquirimos una deuda en cierto
país y tenemos cierta obligación legal
ligada a esta deuda está asociada a la
ley la idea de que se puede pagar esa
deuda con dinero si alguna vez han
escuchado el término de moneda de curso
legal
es a esto a lo que se refiere
seguramente han escuchado de billetes o
monedas que son llamadas monedas de
curso legal y lo de legal quiere decir
que está asociado a las leyes de dicho
país y lo de moneda se refiere a que si
tomamos prestada cierta cantidad del
banco ordenamos comida en algún
restaurante antes de pagar por ella en
cuanto a nosotros ofrecemos la moneda de
curso legal esa deuda ya no va a existir
el hecho de ofrecer esta moneda de curso
legal va a hacer que la deuda deje de
existir y para que vean porque esto
tiene fundamentos imagínense que hace ya
bastantes años muchas veces las personas
solían solicitar préstamos en oro por
ejemplo a finales del siglo 19 cuando se
construían muchos trenes y vías
ferroviarias aumentaba la deuda para
apoyar la construcción de estas y con
frecuencia se daba el caso de que alguna
de esas personas que construían los
trenes
pedía prestada una gran cantidad de
dinero y pedía el préstamo en forma de
oro y se esperaba que esta persona
pagará su deuda
usando oro también quizá agregando algo
de intereses y es por eso que las
personas prestaban en oro
en primer lugar quizás se trataba de
muchas personas que tenían oro y estaban
buscando en qué invertirlo y a cambio a
recibir algo de interés
ahora pensemos qué pasaría si tratáramos
de hacer esto en la actualidad
imaginemos que ahora pedimos prestada
una onza de oro y digamos que en la
actualidad esto corresponde a diez mil
pesos
diez mil pesos corresponden a una onza
de oro y digamos que mientras tenemos el
oro pasa el tiempo nosotros lo
invertimos lo usamos y en lugar de
construir trenes hacemos algo más
moderno pero bueno el tiempo pasa y el
oro aumenta en valor digamos que ahora
vale una onza de oro veinte mil pesos
así que ahora cada onza de oro vale
veinte mil pesos pero si vamos a pagar
exactamente lo que recibimos pues
pagaríamos una onza de oro más ciertos
intereses y nadie tendría razón de
quejarse pero legalmente tenemos el
derecho de pagar nuestra deuda con la
moneda de curso legal del país que
corresponda y si el país donde se hizo
el préstamo fue méxico pues tenemos el
derecho de pagar nuestra
usando pesos los 10 mil pesos que
corresponden y con el hecho de ofrecer
este dinero a las personas que nos
hicieron el préstamo ya no tendríamos la
deuda pero de hecho hacer esto
significaría que estamos pagando
solamente la mitad de una onza de oro ya
que conforme pasó el tiempo el peso se
devaluó al menos comparándolo con el oro
y ahora a los 10 mil pesos sólo sirven
para adquirir media onza de oro y se
pueden imaginar a las personas pues poco
contentas con esto y con esto podemos
decir que la función de estándar de pago
diferido tiene razón en estar aparte de
las otras funciones ya que podemos
argumentar que la moneda en la economía
actual está enlazada con el sistema
legal del país asociado y con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo